we got jenna back here so let's see what
jenna's got for us how you doing jenna
hey sterling how are you fantastic
fantastic the reason i was calling is
because i actually think this is such an
important conversation
um i
find that
one of the biggest killers in the mood
like when you're trying to set a mood is
a guy who can't
he can't really help you get there
because he can't use his words
effectively
um so one of the things like i was the
one who super chatted earlier um i
actually do
phone
for a living
um so like i come across it a lot and i
think what you're doing is so important
because men don't
you're not there's something that's you
lina ah yeah yeah yeah okay
so so you're a phone sex operator yeah
got it okay
yeah so i spend a lot of time listening
to men's fantasy so learning how to just
kind of articulate certain things in
certain ways
it works the same way with women like
you were talking about it earlier like
the thing with being called daddy we
like the dominance aspect that you were
talking about we love that but not a lot
of men are comfort comfortable or
confident enough to do it properly so
instead of it
so when just from a female perspective
instead of a guy like yourself coming in
front of me and going i want you to take
off your clothes and i want you to do it
now
when you do it with your confidence my
response is going to be yes daddy
if somebody else does it i'm going to be
like oh okay
but he wouldn't say it
he wouldn't he wouldn't say it like i
would you know he'd be like uh uh take
you
yeah
can you take your clothes off
he'd have that hesitation in his voice
exactly exactly i experience it all the
time and you would even think that when
men are paying for a chance to live out
their fantasy with you that they would
have a little more confidence doing it
even in those cases you would be
surprised how little imagination the
average person has
or the average male has
but but i really appreciate what you're
offering
thank you can i ask you something i want
to ask you a question because i've asked
i've asked this question to um two porn
stars that i've interviewed before
how it if you're in bed with a man
and he
forget even that he's not dirty talking
right if he makes absolutely no noise
in the bedroom yeah how old does that
make you feel
that is one of the biggest mood killers
you could possibly imagine
guys i'm not even
if there's one thing the same way that
you guys want a response from us we want
a response from you so a guy who's like
pounding away and like you could tell
that this is like his first shot at sex
in a really long time it's so
uncomfortable
like you would be surprised how little
you guys have to actually do to show us
that you're interested in us sexually so
for example there is nothing more
at least for me there's nothing sexier
for me than like if you're laying on
your back he's right on top of you and
he just leans into your ear and all you
hear is
[ __ ]
yeah
that's enough besides this because
there are so many guys who are even shy
about just moaning and groaning in the
bedroom
it's little
comfortable
taking it to dirty talk it makes you so
uncomfortable it makes you so insecure
and and also a lot of can you say that
sorry to try to have on the point but
it makes you feel insecure is that
correct jenny yeah because it's uh have
you ever watched the show sons of
anarchy
no i have not there's a line in it um
that the mother says and it's very very
true men want to know that you love them
and women want to know that you want
them we want to feel wanted and and when
you don't kind of give us that response
especially since like they face it the
majority of women we live our lives
feeling very insecure
and sex brings out most of our
insecurities that's why after a certain
age a lot of us want to have sex with
the lights off because we have we have a
lot of things going on with us so little
things especially if you're the strong
silent type just moaning a little
something in her ear just a little bit
of
um
just just something like i've always i
personally enjoy dirty talk and i've
always been good at it that's part of
how i got into
what i do now but
it's amazing how little you guys
communicate and i think a lot of that
bleeds into your relationship problems
too
jenna do you know any women that don't
like dirty talk
there is abs the only women who don't
like dirty talk are women who are
genuinely and i mean this dead inside
well thank you thank you for the growing
glowing recommendation jenna thank you
thank you sterling take care bye-bye
it's always good to have uh a woman call
in on the show
you know ladies the show's open for
everybody you know young old man woman
feel free that's you know
and you know they've been here it's the
reason i asked you that question was
because when when i have asked female
porn stars the exact same question
they've said basically the exact she
mentioned this sort of this idea of
making her feel insecure they've used
similar language they've said things
like if he's not making any noise at all
i don't think he likes me right even
though his erect penis is inside of her
she still isn't she's like insecure
about that because you're not expressing
your desire your enjoyment of it yeah
and the interesting thing about noise
and and the volume and the intensity of
it is like women are generally louder
than men i think um i think the term is
female copulatory vocalization from evo
psych
and
you know we can get into all those
reasons
some other time but you don't want to be
silent i mean you don't want to go
beyond her but definitely come up to her
you know when it comes to your volume
and intensity level don't don't sit
there like a mute absolutely i couldn't
i couldn't agree more yeah and that's
and
and look if if you're you need to start
if that that is like
bare minimum starting point for guys is
like okay learn to be expressive and
moan and groan a little bit like i i do
this thing where i friggin i freaking
growl
and i don't even know i'm doing it i've
had so many girls call me out on it like
but they'll say but they'll say they're
not making fun of me they'll say i love
the way you growl and i'm like i do what
and i don't even know i'm doing it going
uh
have you seen eddie murphy's stand up i
think it was in delirious where he was
talking about
that part of the uh sequence did you
ever see that stand up yeah
oh you got to see it go go watch eddie
murphy delirious you're you're going to
love it it's an old 80s one but it but
it still stands true today right i mean
like
get it get it right through your head
guys that if you want to have a good
experience with women if you want to
have them coming back for more if you
want to lean into areas that are fun and
entertaining and erotic you have to get
playful right like you can't
you can't cookie cut it and you know the
guys that get into the cookie cutter
type of relationships and the very
vanilla type of sexual intimacy in the
encounters they don't generally last
that long i mean you're not getting her
best you know you're just getting and
that's and that's very different from
getting her best
and once you start practicing this stuff
you you'll
you will start enjoying it
as much if not more than she does like
the act of engaging in that is going to
be fun and enjoyable for you and
arousing for you just as much as it is
for her yeah so it's just you just
you're leaving so much on the table
you